today's speed round is brought to you by
verizon peter king mike florio here for
another half hour so let's get to it
which doesn't belong in y
edition of the verizon 5g speed round
peter
let's begin with quarterbacks taken in
round one
after the first two picks in the draft
trey lance
justin fields mac jones which doesn't
belong and why
i would say trey lance because i think
it is most
likely that those other two guys are
going to play before
trey lance does even though that would
you would think that's a surprise
because trey lance goes number three but
i think if garoppolo stays healthy and
the 49ers are winning
he hangs on to the job i'll say it's
justin fields because
i think he's got the easiest path to
being the week one starter
even though when the bears went down
this road in 2017
with mitchell trubisky they did give
mike glennon
the first month of the season to prove
that he wasn't the answer
but i think fields will leapfrog andy
dalton
and play week one and i think after i've
had a chance because we've
kind of gone back and forth on this and
i'm i'm content to say now i think
fields is the most likely to be the week
one starter i may have said something
different earlier this week
i really can't recall but if you can't
beat out andy dalton all due respect to
andy dalton
why why did they give up next year's
first round pick to go get you it's that
simple
and i think fields has every chance and
will be given every chance to beat out
andy dalton peter
i think you're right but i don't
necessarily think that
uh i mean i think he's definitely gonna
play before lance does
um and and whether that's week one or
week five
you know it's coming kyle trask
kellen monde davis mills that was the
next cut of quarterback taken
late round two early round three by the
buccaneers vikings and texans
respectively
which doesn't belong and why trask monde
mills
i'd say davis mills that to me was the
the one pick in this draft of every pick
other than say alex leatherwood
where i just said what you got to be
kidding me alex leatherwood
17. but to me davis mills
was so compelling because it said so
much
and i don't care that nick caserio says
that
this in essence this has nothing to do
with
with uh desean watson yes it does it
certainly does
when you have one pick in the top 80 and
you pick a quarterback
even though the only franchise player on
your team
right now is a quarterback oh it says a
lot about the quarterback
so to me i think davis mills is the one
that
totally sticks out there i i think the
ship has sailed on deshaun watson in the
texans the question is when will they be
able to trade him and will they be able
to find a partner before he potentially
lands on the commissioner exempt list
all year long and they pay him more than
10 million dollars to not play that's
what they're
hoping to avoid either way he's not
going to be on the field for them this
year
or ever so they got to move forward and
they've got tyrod taylor
for now and and they traded for ryan
finley and now they use that draft pick
on davis mills
to me the one that doesn't stand out is
kellen monde or that does stand out
among the others is calaman because i
think he's in the perfect position
to both develop and compete
and i look the vikings are in a tough
contractual spot with kirk cousins and i
don't think he's going to be there 2023.
and cousins has told me i i feel no
compulsion to extend my contract
well the vikings aren't going to be able
to franchise tag him as a practical
matter
they got to have a plan b and plan b
between now and the end of the 2022
season could become plan a
if kellman develops the way that he
could and the fact that sims had him
installed at number four on his list
ahead of fields and lance
really stands out to me so i'm
fascinated by what mond
possibly can do jamar chase jalen waddle
devonta smith the top three receivers
drafted by the bengals
the dolphins and the eagles respectively
which doesn't belong and why
i think jalen waddle because not only is
he going to be used
obviously a lot in the regular offense
and perhaps every down
but i also think that uh brian florey's
going to use him
as an explosive player in the return
game
um it's possible not not likely but it's
possible
that they have drafted a wide receiver
and they have drafted devin hester
you know because he has the kind of
return ability
the way they look at this guy he has the
kind of return ability
that could impact the game as much as
his ability as a receiver
i'm gonna go with smith number one
because i think he's incredibly talented
and he was unfairly knocked for only
being 166 pounds at the indianapolis
medical check but also the psychology of
receivers
being drafted not the first one off the
board and also not the first one from
your school
off the board that extra level of
motivation that will light the fire
for a guy like devonta smith to be even
better
than he yeah otherwise would have been
if he'd been the first receiver taken
it's the michael thomas dynamic when he
felt a round two behind a bunch of
receivers who ended up being
frankly nothing in the nfl that pissed
him off so much peter
that it willed him to be great and i
think devante smith can take the fact
that
jalen waddle went before him jamar chase
went before him he fell
down to the bottom of the top ten that
he can use that
as that extra thing that maybe separates
him in a way that he otherwise wouldn't
have separated
here's the one thing that really sticks
out in my pre-draft research
this year i had a veteran general
manager who is not given to saying such
things
and he said peter devonte smith is one
of the best football players
i've ever scouted and you know
you hear that you say whoa that's that's
an amazing statement
from a guy who's been around the league
for as long as this guy has
and i think the reason why so many
people fell in love with davonte smith
and why in my opinion if he continues to
do this in philadelphia
he will be a huge fan favorite
and that is he even at his size
he is a physical receiver who wins the
contested balls
and you know most of the guys who are
going to cover him are going to be
bigger than he is
so that is what is going to be really
interesting to watch
i'm fascinated by the pick of devonta
smith i think that's going to be
such a he's going to be such a fun
player to watch in the next few years
let's flip it over to the defense
jeremiah owosu-koromoa of the browns
christian barmore of the patriots and
trevin morig
defensive players who slipped in the
draft which doesn't belong and why
i will say christian bar more because uh
and without any doubt every team
has a plan for who they pick in this
draft
but i think christian barmore is
interesting to consider
in this case because if you get drafted
by
the patriots as an interior defensive
lineman
bill belichick has an exact thought
about how you're going to be used and
how you're going to be used from
opening day on and so my feeling is that
you are going to see
probably as an impact player early on
christian burma have the best chance to
be that
and these guys slipped out of round one
because there was some talk about his
work ethic even though nick saban came
out
and defended him and belichick's got
that pipeline to nick saban
i'm sure belichick knows everything
there is to know about nick saban the
king of the ands and the butts
in the draft reports and you're going to
get
a candid unvarnished look from saban and
belichick clearly
uh satisfied with that i'll go with osu
coramoa the browns considered taking him
in round one
he continued the slide to round two they
traded up to get him with the macho man
pick remember macho man preening around
on the stage not the real macho man
but a guy who impersonates him they got
a will sue coramo and they were thrilled
to get him three down linebacker
will be on the field we'll make things
happen and gives them a nice presence
between an excellent
front line of the defense and a very
good back end
he could end up being a great player in
that defense all right
general managers criticized for their
drafts this year which doesn't belong
and why mike mayok kevin colbert nick
casario i don't know why culbert's on
the list maybe he doesn't bull
he doesn't belong just for that reason
but mayonn colbert kevin colbert is not
going along on this list
kevin colbert doesn't belong on this
list and i i think probably people put
him on the list because they're saying
why did you pick naji harris instead of
the best available offensive lineman
you know at 24. and i think that the
the steelers have something in mind and
what they have in mind
is using najee harris as what he
wants to be in the nfl and i talked to
him last saturday
and and what he wants to be is he wants
to be in every down running back who you
who is used the way they used le'veon
bell
that used a lot in the passing game used
obviously between the tackles
but obviously having enough juice to get
outside the tackles
as well and so i think the steelers
thought
let's get this great offensive weapon
right here
and fill in on the offensive line after
this
where in you know two three rounds two
three four
there are usable players and players we
can work with after that
i i agree with you about that and
colbert told me this week that they do
intend to use him as a three down back
mayhawk stands out to me just because
i feel like he's being set up to be the
next guy out
in las vegas where's gruden the past
week has there been
anything from gruden has he spoken to
anyone did he do any of the press
conference it was all mayak mayak mayok
he's the one who's being hung out to dry
and if they fail this year i think mayok
is the guy
that gruden is gonna push overboard even
though gruden is the guy
who's driving the bus uh and he's driven
it over paul gunther and i think he's
gonna drive it over mike mayhawk unless
the raiders get to the postseason this
year all right let's take a break when
we return our friday pft
live draft we'll do that right after
this
pro football talk is brought to you by
verizon
built right for business
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports